à suivre l'actualité politique
maintenant nous vous le disions dans les
titres michèle alliot-marie la
secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'enseignement était tout à l'heure dans
le jura à poligny elle a visité le lycée
hôtelier à champagnole un lycée
d'enseignement technique et pu étape
importante de sa visite l'école primaire
pasteur de salins étape important parce
que dans cette école sont appliquées
désormais certaines mesures d'urgence
prises par michèle alliot marie
en décembre dernier il avait le brune
arius cédric karine aurélien et sept
autres élèves de cm1 et de cm2 viennent
ici deux fois par semaine pendant une
heure après leur journée de classe
habituelle
l'objectif de ce groupe de rattrapage
intensif et de leur donner toutes leurs
chances pour l'entrée au collège
46e 25% des enfants ne savent pas
correctement lire des qu'eric de vaud a
entendu parler de ce plan de lutte pour
la réussite scolaire
il s'est porté volontaire pour s'occuper
d'ailleurs cela en plus de sa classe de
perfectionnement pendant la journée
deux mois plus tard en janvier et avec
l'autorisation des parents et la pluie
du directeur de l'école les séances
commencé grâce à des tests réguliers
l'instituteur connaît exactement les
lacunes des élèves en lecture et en
écriture et surtout leur progression ils
s'adaptent aux enfants pour eux il ne
s'agit pas seulement d'entendre mais de
comprendre ce qu'ils disent savoir
devenir autonome est aussi important
très motivé leur progrès sont nets des
résultats que l'éducation nationale
voudrait généraliser car cette année
c'est effectivement un plan d'urgence
une sorte de plan orsec pour la réussite
scolaire qui a été mise en place pour
les cours moyens pour ces élèves qui
vont entrer en sixième à partir de
l'année prochaine et grâce aux 300
millions de francs pour une
multiplication partie des crédits c'est
de ce plan de soutien de rattrapage et
bien ce seront tous les élèves de
l'école primaire ayant des difficultés
qui pourront bénéficier de mesures
tendant à les mettre à niveau pour ce
plan d'urgence 13 projets dans le jura
ont été acceptées par l'inspection
académique
une dizaine d'autres
sont en préparation